on est en mode normal maintenant on
installe et c'est là qu'on se marre
comme ça où beaucoup plus vous allez
passer à un niveau supérieur
[Musique]
on va se poser la question de savoir
comment complètement optimisé les photos
sur son iphone 10r pas que sur le 10 r
on peut le faire sur d'autres on peut le
faire sur le 8 le 7 le dissez vrai j'en
passe et des meilleurs vous allez voir
il ya un moyen très simple qui coûte pas
très cher d'avoir des photos de son
complètement optimisé et là je vous
parle pas d'un point de vue logiciel
vous parle vraiment d'un point de vue
matériel ou à venir à bout d'une petite
lentille là dessus c'est franchement
dingue alors si vous suivez mon contenu
si vous suivez vidéo vous savez déjà
partenariat avec rhinochill et nos
chiffres qui en fabriquant de coqs mais
pas seulement
et justement c'est là que ça devient
intéressant parce que dans la gamme de
produits rhinochill je veux la coque
solide suite ça c'est une cote très
classique qui va très bien vous la
prenez vous la mettez derrière votre
smartphone
ça vous fait une protection ça protège
bien ça marche bien ça c'est cool mais
on s'arrête pas là c'est pour ça que
vous en parle parce que ça vraiment
intéressant rhinochill à des optiques
qui sont complètement adaptable alors
certes rhino chine est un partenaire
même si je vous en parle parce que je
trouve ça vraiment un intérêt où j'ai
déjà fait une précédente vidéo dessus
lorsque j'étais en vacances en crète
[Musique]
on
à
et là ils sont sortis une solution que
trois aussi hyper intéressante très
polyvalente c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous en parle aujourd'hui
dans cette pochette j'ai de quoi filmer
en grand-angle en accro en cas de
carence full hd comme je le veux et j'ai
aussi son petit frère par la grand angle
et macro alors je vous montre vous allez
voir ça c'est impressionnant ça c'est
une optique quand même de taille assez
impressionnante et la côte est la plus
petite je voulais des balles
j'installe et après jour tant conditions
du réel ce que ça donne sur l'iphone en
cash en train de filmer en mode
complètement normal sur mon iphone
maintenant je mette la petite dessus
vous aller tout de suite voir la
différence
voilà là s'est élargit davantage ça va
capter davantage plus grand angle et ça
c'est cool parce que lorsque vous voulez
filmé avec votre iphone lorsque vous
êtes en je sais pas vous les films et
des paysages des souvenirs quoi que ce
soit vous allez capter beaucoup plus de
choses ça va être vachement plus
agréable pour un style c'est simple il
me faut ce petit kit en plus alors
rassurez vous je vous ai mis tous les
liens en bord description et en plus
vous avez un tarif réduit chez
rhinochill si toutefois ça vous
intéresse comme ça au moins vous
achèterez dans les meilleures conditions
ça ça vous le permet de le fixer sur
votre coque lino shield et uniquement
sur votre talk rhinochill on le prend on
le pose à l'arrière pas très compliqué
vous prenez votre iphone vous
l'installez de dents jusque là ça
ressemble à ça ça se pose directement de
votre module photo ou si vous choisissez
ce que vous voulez allez on va commencer
par le plus petit on ouvre la petite
partie arrière qui va venir se fixer y
perd facilement vous la prenez vous
faites
hop un demi-tour taxe est fixé
on ouvre et là franchement tout de suite
ça a de la gueule là ce que vous voyez à
l'écran c'est avec l'objectif
je vais l'enlever tout de suite ce n'est
pas la même bon ça c'est cool mais ça ne
s'arrête pas là parce que vous avez
aussi un mode macro là-dessus provins
mode macro il faut enlever cette grosse
partie et garder celle du dessous vous
faire c'est faire un tour dans ce sens
et ça va s'enlever tout simplement et
vous allez retrouver sur votre objectif
macro on peut continuer à la main ça
marche très très bien voilà ça c'est
l'objectif macro ont fait exactement la
même manip
on vient le poser dessus et maintenant
je viens film et là je me colle
complètement dessus je suis hyper net
c'est hyper hyper hyper hyper hyper
hyper bluffant je suis vraiment en train
de coller mon iphone dessus et là comme
ça j'ai la vraie macro et ça c'est super
chouette passe des choses que je veux
pas faire naturellement a condamné parce
que faire uniquement avec un objectif
macro comme ça alors là j'ai la peau
hyper sèche
là je me rendais pas compte que j'avais
la peau aussi sèche mais grâce à la
macro merci beaucoup et j'ai un truc là
de poils de je sais pas ce que c'est
mais ça je peux le faire uniquement avec
l'objectif macro du coup avec ça je peux
faire du grand-angle phare la macro avec
un seul et même objectif et ça
franchement c'est vraiment cool ça vous
allez aller beaucoup plus loin notamment
en termes de qualité 4k hd sur tout ce
que je vous propose c'est de l'installer
et de regarder ce que ça pleure ça
s'installe exactement de la même manière
un quart de tour vous ouvrez et là
franchement ça rien à voir c'est tout de
suite beaucoup plus grand et pour avoir
la macro c'est exactement la même chose
un quart de tour vous continuez ça vaut
davis leur part en exploration dans le
monde merveilleux des poils de monsieur
bretagne et comme je leur approche c'est
ouf quand même qualité du truc c'est ouf
issime ou alors l'idée à mon avis c'est
pas forcément d'aller se regarder les
poils pouvait regarder sans votre pull
aller voir les mailles voir si elles
sont bien faites
la qualité elle est juste complètement
dingos c'est génial on le but de
l'opération après c'est sûr appel à
votre créativité pour les faire vos
photos vos vidéos juste un outil mais
c'est un outil que je trouve hyper cool
on va se faire quelques photos normal
grand-angle feu quelques photos macro
après et franchement je trouve ça hyper
bluffant
bon
objectif dites moi ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous voyez l'utilité est ce
que vous pensez qu'un grand angle et que
liam accro à rajouter en plus comme ça
sur votre smartphone peut vraiment vous
apporter un gain en termes de photos de
vidéos est ce que vous voyez l'utilité
et vous ne marquez tout ça bien
évidemment commentaires nous invite à
rester connectés parce qu'on va parler
toujours plus de techno un peu marrante
de smartphones de telles qu'en règle
générale comme ça on en saura toujours
plus n'hésitez pas à les consulter ma
playlist pour découvrir tous les
derniers smartphones voire lequel vous
plaît oui quoi comment comme ça on en
débat voilà à bientôt 12 ans